the voter only has the collective
conscience of the people who are in
public office the 72 year old former
governor says he's waited patiently for
someone to emerge and restore common
sense at City Hall Caetano says no one
has
Honolulu's rail transit project the
first ever for Hawaii gets one point 55
billion federal dollars high attano is
opposed to rail transit which he says
will cost two billion more than the
estimated 5.3 billion my name is Ben
kakano I'm a former governor two-term
governor of this state I'm a liberal
Democrat I'm liberal on social issues
fiscally I'm kind of conservative and
because I was a former chairman the Ways
and Means Committee and my eight years
as governor not to understand the fiscal
issues regarding mistake this state has
a retirement system which has a
tremendous unfunded liability eight
billion dollars for the state health
system health fund for the benefits of
the state and county employees unfunded
liability is 14 billion on the city side
the FTA is through the city and managed
to get a consent decree because the city
had neglected the sewers of four billion
dollars huge huge that you know facing
the people of this particular city now
in the future all of this that was
beginning to price our young people and
our senior citizens from living in this
city we only have nine hundred and fifty
three thousand people on this island
today in 2030 according to the state
population projections it'll be at about
one point two it's not enough for this
kind of debt as governor also realized
that the biggest issue here for and
probably in many mainland states as well
the increasing cost of the public
workers we have the most generous
benefit package for state employees and
for County
employees probably in the nation 21 days
sick leave
21 days vacation 13 paid holidays taught
over 55 days you can't produce we're not
working I'm a liberal Democrat I've been
Pro labor all my political career but it
is an issue politically the public
worker unions here become very very
powerful they're not being led by people
who understand that it is in the workers
interests for them to do things now
which will address the unfunded
liabilities the elected officials have a
couple choices you raise taxes or you
cut services or you do a little bit of
both it's difficult to cut sewers you
know you can't do it water for example
those things are essential and you can't
do much about that so you need to watch
spending or what will happen and I
predict is they're gonna end up raising
taxes either that or the city will go
bankrupt when you look at these kind of
spending in isolation it may not make
much of an impact on the public in
general but when you see this happening
not only here but in in other places on
the mainland and when you consider some
of the huge issues facing the federal
government whether it would be Social
Security Medicare or those kind of big
programs everybody should be concerned
oftentimes you find social and cultural
issues given more importance you know
then issues which really will affect our
country down the road our infrastructure
for example is no secret that our
airports are like third world airports
compared to Seoul Korea or Japan or even
Europe you know because we haven't been
paying attention to those things our
politicians get diverted by you know
issues like same-sex marriage or
abortion and stuff like that then you
debate on guns for example okay that's
taken a lot of energy and it
from debates which I think are more
important the biggest deterrent to any
kind of shenanigans by the government or
people in the government is public
knowledge and the public knows about
something and they get upset there's
nothing more powerful than that so
transparency is very very important the
problem is that when you have so much
power on one side you don't have much
transparency in a state where it's
basically one party has all the power
there's no really loyal opposition to
try and balance things out in the end
what happens is that when the special
interest becomes too powerful the voter
only has the collective conscience of
the people who are in public office Ben
cayetano's political career spans three
decades but last night he suffered his
first defeat
you